اذا رغم الانسحابات الاسرائيليه اللافته
للنظر في المنطقه الشماليه محيط مدينه غزه
احياء الشماليه من مدينه غزه والحياء
الشماليه الشرقيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من
مدينه غزه الا ان المنطقه الشماليه من
قطاع غزه لا تزال تشهد عمليات للمقاومه
عنيفه وكثيفه للغايه كما شاهدنا قبل قليل
في المنطقه الوسطى ايضا ل فيديو سرايا
القدس كتابه القسام كانت قد اعلنت خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه عن تقريبا 10 الى 11
استهدافا في المنطقه الشماليه فقط بعيدا
عن منطقه الوسط او خانيونس اذا عندما
نتحدث عن المنطقه الشماليه مع تصريح وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت بان هناك بعض
جيوب المقاومه الفلسطينيه في المنطقه
الشماليه لا يمكن السيطره عليها الا اننا
نتحدث عن وقائع تتحدث عن ضربات عنيفه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في حيي التفاح والدرج
استهداف واستدراج لقوات اسرائيليه راجله
في هذه المنطقه رغم الانسحاب الاسرائيلي
من هذه المنطقه نتحدث ايضا عن منطقه
جباليا لا نتحدث عن منطقه مخيم جباليا
انما نتحدث عن المنطقه الشرقيه من جباليا
البلد نتحدث عن منطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه في
محيط تل الهواء والشيخ عجلين في المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه هذه النقاط ترسم لنا
ملامح التوغل الاسرائيليه العمليات
الخاطفه ان صح التعبير في هذه المناطق رغم
الانسحاب الاسرائيلي والتواجد في المنطقه
الشرقيه شرقي الشجاعيه في المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه وعندما نتحد المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه نتحدث عن اطراف بيت حنون
في هذه المنطقه الاليات الاسرائيليه
متواجده المنطقه الشماليه من منطقه تل
الهواء او عفوا تل الهواء بيت لاهيه في
هذه المنطقه المنطقه الشماليه وايضا نتحدث
عن التواجد الابرز للقوات الاسرائيليه في
شمال قطاع غزه في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
مدينه غزه على شكل هذا القاطع منطقه جحر
ديك و حي الزيتون في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
مدينه غزه هذه القوات تتوغل لتضرب في
المنطقه وتتوغل لتضرب ولكنها في المقابل
تتعرض لصد وضربات واضحه ومحدده ودقيقه من
قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في المنطقه
الشماليه اذا المنطقه الشماليه لا تزال
تشهد عمليات نوعيه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
رغم الانسحابات واعاده التموضع الاسرائيلي
في المنطقه الوسطى يحاول الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التوغل اكثر والسيطره على مخيم
البريج في هذه المنطقه يضغط على البريج من
الجهه الشرقيه من الجهه الشماليه في الجهه
الشرقيه يتعرض لضربات من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وشاهدنا مقطع فيديو سرايا
القدس التي استهدفت فيه الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تحاول الضغط على البريج
الذهاب سريعا الى خانيونس مركز العمليات
الرئيسي يعجز الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حتى هذه
اللحظه عن السيطره او الدخول او التوغل
الى عمق مدينه خان يونس يتعرض لضربات
عنيفه في المنطقه الشرقيه والشماليه
والشماليه الشرقيه من خان يونس وحتى هذه
اللحظه لم ل يستطع التوغل في قلب مدينه
خان يونس رغم الضغط الكبير الذي شكله على
هذه المنطقه من هذه الاتجاهات الشماليه
الشرقيه والشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه